guys I think we have to call it Disney's
on a longer winning streak now than they
were with the 90s Renaissance Zootopia
yeah Disney is on a roll they have been
on a roll since tangled and they have
done it again with this one this movie
has a lot going for it it is fun it's
funny it is high-energy but a knows when
to slow down it's got some really
terrific messages in it it's got great
characters just from start to finish
it's very well thought out just starting
with how it approaches the idea of these
anthropomorphized animals because I mean
let's be honest and a city inhabited by
animals not exactly new an animation
although to be fair generally more of
the realm of TV animation than feature
film but normally it's just something
that just is it's animals yeah that's
just what happens here they actually put
some effort into explaining it now
normally that's the sort of concept like
don't over explain it you don't need to
but the they come at it from this
approach of you know they everyone has
evolved but they do still have sort of
that animal instinct underlying and
there are certain prejudice is even
involved in that prayer somewhat
prejudice against predators they tend to
fear them predators are prejudiced
against prey feeling that they are meek
and minor and you're not really worth
the effort large animals are prejudiced
against small ones and there's all this
sort of thing and it's all very baked
into the idea that yes they've evolved
and they're living together now but you
know what sort of makes up those those
core divisions from way back when
everyone was savaged that still
underlies everything but I'm kind of
getting ahead into some of the messages
of the thing let's talk about story
we're gonna focus on this bunny
character who wants to be a cop now
there's never been a bunny cop before
cops tend to be large animals large
imposing animals rhinoceros is the
captains and ox Jaguars elephants things
like that so a bunny cop is kind of a
joke but she has been dreaming of this
her whole life and she's gonna tackle it
as best as she can as she soon finds
herself wrapped up in something that is
much bigger than she imagined and she's
on a compress
to try and figure out what is going on
and now the partially out of desperation
she ends up broke me in the help of this
Fox from the city now she herself is
actually new to the city so she's not as
familiar with everything going on and
the people and the places and all that
so the Fox he's a bit of a con artist
but he knows the streets so the two of
them together are on this case it starts
out as a missing mammals case but it
becomes something much bigger pretty
much all the humor is derived from the
way in which the characters animal
nature sort of impedes on their more
human-like lives that they tend to be
living I mean the the sloths working at
the DMV is something that most people
have seen now it's been in the trails
but that really does epitomize what I'm
talking about that is very much in the
nature of the humor and there's some
phenomenal jokes there's also some
really great jokes for the adults there
are things that'll happen that the film
doesn't even stop to let you know it's a
joke but the adults who are paying
attention will get it and they'll just
and then kids they'll get it much later
when they get older the voice cast is
all really solid on this everybody does
good work I mean the bet by far the best
is the rabbit and the Fox they've got
great chemistry together the characters
are fun but you kind of want to talk
about the messages that the film is
carrying because late because if you
couldn't guess from my earlier
description there's a lot of tackling of
some pretty weighty issues dealing with
prejudice where you come from what
people tend to think about you because
of your background or what you look like
or what is in your DNA and it's not
exactly subtle I heard some people
coming out of the movies saying boy that
was really on the nose and you know it
is but also keep in mind who the target
audience for this thing is and I think
for a movie for kids it is pretty subtle
because the movie at no point actually
stops in turns to the camera and goes
now kids the lessons a day like it's the
end of a GI Joe cartoon or something
know it is all woven into the narrative
and you know to adult eyes it's pretty
blunt but I think for kids it's really
very well integrated at and at a level
that doesn't actually intrude on the
story it's actually it informs the story
even it's very organically mixed in
they don't stop the story they're
telling in order to give you messages
the message and the story are actually
completely interwoven and the fact that
they managed to do that not kill the
pacing keep it moving keep it fun keep
it funny yeah this this is just another
stellar movie I would say it's better
than B hero six which I liked a lot
maybe not quite as good as wreck-it
Ralph but then wreck-it Ralph just kind
of hit my own buttons and got me right
there so maybe on par with that but I
mean it's just it's good it's really
good absolutely if you've got kids take
them to see it they'll love it you will
probably have a good time to it but even
if you're like me and you're an adult
who does appreciate animations yeah go
see it it's gonna be worth your time so
that's nutopia what do you guys think
about Disney's current streak is it
rivaling the 90s Disney Renaissance I
kind of think it is at this point if I'm
looking past my nostalgia goggles and
being honest but what do you think about
that whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it please do not forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter a
council of geeks look for the council of
geeks podcast on iTunes and stitcher and
as for me I'll be back as soon as I can
get my next fix